he is the best player in the world he's
the world champion I think Hikaru said
it best he is Magnus Carlson and he
joins us on the state of chess.com
Magnus thanks for being here man
thank you I uh I want to dive in to a
question that I know you answered in
August when we threw together that sort
of quick quick video to announce this
thing for those people who don't know
there's been a lot to this right and and
a lot of work to make this happen but
for you again what made you know for a
company that bears your likeness a
company that you built and helped found
that this was the right thing to do for
chess for the opportunity for you
yourself if you could just speak broadly
hand you the mic what what makes you
excited about this and what made you
feel like this was the right thing to do
I think it's going to be great for both
fans and and players a sim a simple a
stat that uh now that it will be easier
for all the best players to
uh to sort of compete in the same event
and it will be easier for the the fans
to to follow and that's uh really an
exciting prospect for for me as well to
be constantly competing with the with
the best in World online and probably
even more frequently than than I used to
yep for you is it is it does it feel
mostly about about the the the tour and
and bringing all the players together
the the other things that you've been
invested in like your app for example my
my son wanted to say he can't wait to
he's played your five-year-old Magnus
Carlson and wants to play it with the
other Bots are there anything else you
would say kind of broadly that you that
you know gets you pumped about about
this or for you is it mainly about about
the tour and all the players Under One
Roof
uh for me as a chess player uh it that's
certainly a big motivation but uh I'm of
course a shareholders as well in in the
play Management Group and and for that
it's also exciting all the all the new
possibilities that we have both with um
with our apps and and adjustable
um
the the new possibilities for for
integration there so it's going to be
it's going to be fun to see and
hopefully uh generally just
it's great for 3D um for the chess fans
and um
yeah yeah
makes sense I I want to stay on the
topic then as a player we're gonna make
this a little casual kind of podcast
style I think for a lot of people the
questions they have are what do you feel
is next for you as a player what is left
for you to accomplish at this point in
your career right this was a big year
you declined the the opportunity to
defend the traditional the classical
World Chess Championship you're super
excited about the evolving formats of
online chess but how what are your
Ambitions left in your over-the-board
chess career 2900 rating and how do you
approach that and what are your thoughts
about what remains for you to to kind of
accomplish over the over the years to
come
well I don't have a lot of Ambitions for
for what to to accomplish but I love the
game I love playing so that's that's all
the ambition that I that I really need
and uh that's why I'm gonna continue to
to compete in the events that I um that
I enjoy
yep okay makes sense hey then moving on
um from the the over the board uh
Ambitions because you're right you don't
have a lot of Ambitions needed needed
there uh makes sense but talking about
the evolution then the game broadly
right 200 000 plus people tuned in to
you and Hikaru on Sunday and the fans
clearly love you throwing down in fast
time controls not just against Hikaru
but others you you know you're
documented as kind of wanting wanting
there to be an evolution and to embrace
faster time patrols because you feel
like it's the more sporting element
um in some of your you know kind of uh
closed-door discussions with fide but
talk about that a little bit if you
would about what you feel is important
for the game as it's evolving you with
these online events that lead to these
live kind of finals and what what do you
think is important to see in these in
these modern chess formats to make sure
that the content Remains the most
exciting for fans
I I think your summarized it pretty
pretty well there uh I would also like
to mention uh Fisher random chess uh
which I would love to see more of in a
uh classical or at least slower time
Patrol when it comes to regular uh
chess I feel that
um
I fill out uh classical probably will be
sort of phased out a little bit at least
at the at the top level
um at least that's what I think sort of
should should happen
um I think
that um
the possibilities for discovering new
ideas in the opening especially are are
somewhat limited and
um you can see that in faster time
controls there's still more than enough
scope to to play and the game works in
in a great way obviously this is
at the top level at other levels it
doesn't doesn't matter as much
um
but but yeah faster time controls it
matters a lot less there
um
it's probably better to have it that way
because people have the familiarity with
the with the the positions people can
see their own theory that
um they play without the games becoming
too too boring so so
um yeah I think uh
um that's one of the big reasons why
um
why faster chess is the is the way to to
go also a lot of the
uh audience or most of the audience is
online anyway so I think there's no
reason why we shouldn't play the games
mostly online as well
yeah it makes sense that I want to
double click on that because there's
there's still a lot of comparisons as
there should be right online chess is
different than over the board I mean
physically it feels different like the
energy of your opponent right is
different but but online chess is where
by far more more and more players are
playing in millions of games do you what
do you feel is the difference in your
approach and maybe even quality of play
like do you do you feel a difference
online versus over the board or do you
feel like in five years if you were
looking at Crystal Ball that'll be a
thing of the past that the the modern
generation is is playing just as high
quality online as they are over the
board or what are your thoughts on just
the comparisons there between online and
OTB
I feel like I play in speeches I play a
little bit better online probably uh
probably because
I'm more used to to that but it's too as
you said yeah it's two slightly
different ways of of seeing the
the bar but overall I'm not sure it
really
uh in the long run it will matter too
much in in terms of the um of the
quality I also really like the hybrid
events where you play online but in
person in more of a
Esports setting
um I think uh a lot can be be done there
in the in the future to make that very
very exciting as well
on that note were you were you surprised
by the record viewership that was it was
the most watched chest show second only
to game six of the uh 2021 World Chess
Championship that you may or may not
remember I have been you were a part of
that so this show on Sunday with Hikaru
was the second most watched single chess
show we've we've ever had and do you
feel like the SCC style and format is
perfectly designed for what you said
that you really like those hybrid events
with playing on a computer but in person
with an opponent for fans maybe in a
live audience
yeah I think that's uh that's a great
idea
um and uh
I'd definitely to want to be a part of
of something like that
okay yeah were you surprised by the
viewership or you're like no I expect
throwing down with Hikaru I expected
that
oh I expected it to be popular
um yeah the exact numbers I don't sure
they haven't have an opinion on uh
except that
um yeah if it's comparable with the with
the classical World Championship
um then then that's uh the good that's a
good thing and I think in the in the
future we'll probably see that
online events will just be more and more
popular and um also we'll see what
happens for the next classical World
Championship who knows great well okay
we're starting to get a bunch of
questions from the community and we're
going to dive in there and uh let the
fans get some I'm gonna
I want to double click on one other
question you said from earlier and then
we're going to dive into it you said
that you think that from a classical
time control perspective maybe Fisher
random should be actually what we're
playing shorter time controls
traditional chess do you do you see a
future where you would want to be
competing in in slow Fisher random land
object even slower than maybe the time
controls you've played so far
oh yeah for sure I'd love to see that in
the near in the near future I mean
that's really one of my main wishes for
for chess
coming up is to play slower fishing
random chess
um true there are going to be some
positions that are
um
just fundamentally a little bit boring
where you sort of have to follow
symmetry for the first most but I think
there are going to be so many
possibilities
um
uh as as well and I feel like the
formats that we have had now for future
random they've been they've been
exciting enough but
if you have a little bit more time then
you actually have some more scope to
really dig into the position and to see
the sort of subtle differences there
there are between those positions and
sort of regular chest positions so I'm
all all for for that both from sporting
uh perspective and just for the from the
perspective of um of learning really
yeah I was just going to ask that you
you said the word sporting and I know in
the conversations you and I have had
that you feel like that's a big part of
why you feel faster time controls might
be more reflective of of a player's
all-around skills the sporting element
of real-time reaction solving it in real
time versus versus the computer at home
and you feel like Fisher random might be
the the evolution of really challenging
the sporting element of a top player I
guess summarize it makes sense all right
yeah that's good that's true that's true
yeah
the the sport of duck chess has become
popular I'm going to jump to our first
Community question from two of them our
own chesscom trim asks whether you've
played duck just yet and then chess weeb
and chat wanted to ask whether whether
you're going to be playing in a duck
Chess Championship so have you played
duck chess and would you want to become
the first ever World duck chess champion
I haven't played deck chess but I I
watched
Hammer stream a little bit of duck chest
the other day I thought uh okay let me
try to sit through one game of this
um my first impression was uh
um was like Whoever thought of duck
chess just thought how can I
take chess and make it
just uh really boring uh it seems that
the games are just a lot
a lot slower it's harder to Checkmate uh
I guess there are some other weird
tactics but I just I just found it uh
incredibly boring but I know that other
people like it so that's that's fine
it's funny I actually had a similar
experience it was I find it painful not
boring I was playing IRL duck chess and
getting abused because the duck just sat
in the middle of the center ponds and I
can never figure out anyway uh slow
learner over here um all right we're
going to continue to work through
questions we have one from Mommy game
question for Magnus will we see more
from the maskinson uh Twitch in the
future the we know you you have uh your
own twitch channel right
um and you you've streamed from some of
the um the office Bill club and what are
your thoughts on on that
I have to say that your
um pronunciation is abysmal but uh apart
you're gonna call me out for that I'm
sorry I'm I'm also reading in real time
go ahead
uh yeah I think uh muskanistan will be
uh we'll be back
um that's for um that's for sure for for
different uh different events so um
muskanistan has never been
has never been retired he's just been
been resting and he uh maybe he may be
coming back in the near near future or
at least in the medium future
moscon isn't mosque Nissan yeah
okay all right
all right well there you have it and and
I'm gonna I'm gonna kind of quickly jump
to the next one from Anita drink which
wants to know what your plans are as a
streamer commentator and obviously you
just said maybe maybe a return of that
twitch Channel I know you have different
feelings about you know streaming while
playing
um what tell the fans how you feel about
that when when you enjoy it and when you
don't and what are your thoughts on
streaming while playing in or doing
other stuff
uh well I haven't done it too much but
I've I generally find it interesting and
I think sometimes if your brain is not
working so well it can be it can be you
useful because you sort of articulate
your your thoughts a little bit
um and I I have found it at times useful
um
but um
I think it takes a little bit of time
getting
getting used to for sure as for
commentating yeah I
I like uh I like doing that I mean yeah
that's something something that I um
occasionally enjoy a lot
got it cool all right next question from
TJ heezy wants to know uh I'm gonna kind
of summarize it whether there's anyone
you've yet to have a good Blitz session
against on chess.com that you'd like to
so kind of summarizing we know you've
thrown down against many but is there
someone out there that you would love to
throw down in an epic an epic you know
Bender of a blitz session
throw it down right here throw the
gauntlet down challenge them
yeah I mean there are there are a lot of
people that I haven't uh that I haven't
played
um
I mean alresa is probably the best best
player that I haven't that I haven't
faced in a
well actually I don't need to get more
online chess again single in in the game
in the single game but also
I think it makes sense that uh if you're
going to play you know the very very
best the very toughest opponent at
the most exciting time controls
um then that's maybe something not
something you do casually maybe that's
something you do in a
sort of a more
um serious match
um yeah but um are you previewing
something maybe against guys like Hikaru
or Ali Reza Maybe
no we'll see we'll see uh but uh I I can
say like on in general uh terms I mean
something I'm
definitely interested in like I love
playing playing Blitz and playing
against some of the
well I mean the very the very best and
serious matches I mean there's nothing
more exciting than that
yeah I'll I'll say that um while we said
this is a show of many announcements um
there will be more announcements to come
and teas that of course we're working on
all we can to maybe have some fun fun
things like that that's all I'll say but
all right sticking on the comment of Ali
Reza and we want him to play more online
chess if he's watching uh I'm gonna I'm
gonna go to a question that you get a
lot but we're gonna ask it because I
think the fans just love hearing your
thoughts on it uh m-o-e underscore GE
Moji wants to know who do you feel is uh
is the strongest from these young chess
guys maybe your opinion changes from
time to time so I know I'm giving you a
question you've had forgive me for that
but your thoughts on you just threw down
against gukesh right you've seen what
nihal Soren's been doing Ali Reza
ferrugia your quick hit list on on some
of these young guys coming up who uh who
you have circled
well obviously uh Alvarez has Head and
Shoulders above
everybody else when it comes to
basically every every format
um
but um
yeah among among the others I wouldn't
say there's
um if if you're talking as an old
rounder I don't think there's anybody
who really stands out like
all of them have very distinct strengths
and and weaknesses which is
um which is to be expected from uh from
people at that stage in their career
people like Ali Reza who are who is so
well-rounded in all or formats and is
basically
um
just one of the top guys means it's rare
to be that I say
as a teenager so for the others yeah a
lot of them are very
uh promising but as I said I wouldn't
say that like
as an all-rounder any of them really
stick out
okay makes sense all right a fun one
here to maybe round it off will we see a
Dr drunkenstein bot you've you've got
your main username and we know that the
the people who love to play Magnus Bots
will will probably get action on those
on chess.com but uh do you uh
do you I don't know what the question is
Dr drunkenstein that's the bot uh the
the name on on the leeches account
you've used but any thoughts about Dr
drunkenstein making a chess.com
appearance
I don't know I haven't thought about uh
I haven't thought about that like one of
my friends uh asios he made a um bot
which um
the the reporter was partly based on
um on hyper bullet games so then you
could see a lot of you know like the
lafang some Queen C2 takes H7 and so on
so it would be fun to build a bot based
on my my drunken bullet games but um I
shouldn't say drunken though because I
was never I was never drunk I was at
most like
um a couple of drinks in in many of
those enjoying yourself yeah it would
would be fun
yep all right well there you have it
maybe we need to to get a bot not just
some Magnus at different ages
um I said before you joined I joke with
Andreas that my my son was super pumped
about you know he actually loved that he
could beat a bot Magnus Carlson even
though he couldn't get past five so
maybe we need a Dr drunkenstein bot with
with more personality so
um yeah
that part is going to be strong though I
have to say it's going to be super
strong that that's crazy in fact maybe
we make hybrid a hybrid car Robot too
and then fans can just watch Magnus
versus Hikaru Bots all day and keep them
keep them satisfied 24 7. so all right
all right I got one more question
um because I know that some of the other
biggest names in the game have signed
with teams and we are bringing back the
pro chess league has anybody approached
you I know you haven't signed or
committed yet your thoughts on whether
you are are wanting to compete this year
and has anybody uh has anybody tried to
recruit you yet
yeah I've been contacted by a couple of
teams so I uh I actually
uh agreed to be on the list for a team
like a couple a couple hours ago
actually so that's pretty you want to
break the news and it's can you bring it
tell us
okay I don't I don't know this so I'm
I'm super excited so I'm not promising
that I'll even play this season uh but
it's uh it's very much possible
okay well there you have it Magnus
Carlson is committed to a protest League
team I know I mean you did enjoy that
event right obviously we've all we've
all been torn up inside over the last
couple years that we haven't been able
to to do as many things together but now
the future the future is won and just to
speak of the PCO whether you play or not
you enjoy that that league right and
maybe give your thoughts on that type of
idea like Global team chess right an
online kind of Olympiad feel with free
agents your thoughts on the PCL and what
about that event that you like
yeah I enjoyed the the first season that
we played a lot with the uh
Norwegian team obviously it have been
Revelations about that team but
after the fact that I will not we were
gonna avoid all the controversial topics
we've been through for the last six
months but you did it you're right we
we've been through some stuff over the
last few months together you're right
that's uh okay but
um uh now I've I enjoyed the uh uh the
format a lot
um
uh I remember I mean speaking of
drunkenstein like
um that was one of the original uh
sessions like there was one one of these
rounds where you played Eight Games
Against One Division or something that
did play that from a bar once having a
few drinks so that was that was a lot of
fun and I think I scored seven and a
half of that time uh so yeah it's it's
it's uh it's a great um
great event uh find some camaraderie but
in in the team and um
that I guess now there's a
there's an in-person final as well at
least I I hope so because that's what
we're that's what we're trying for with
with with many of our events in the
future but yes so um yeah we did it in
2018 and in 2019 and and I definitely
think that the PCL is kind of built for
for that type of live kind of Esports
thing so
yeah
all right man well we're gonna let you
go thank you to the to the community for
for questions Magnus thank you so much
for your time man obviously this is it's
a big day it feels uh it feels a little
bit like throwing the throwing the ring
into Mordor like it's done it's it's
been it's been a very long journey but
um for everybody this this uh means the
world to have you and and we're pumped
about the future so thanks for being
with us and uh for everything you do for
the game
no thank you so much and I'm definitely
excited for the all the possibilities we
have for for the future uh it's going to
be a great age for for chess I I believe